hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
in this video we're gonna be doing some
stress test gaming on both the 2018 and
2020 iPad pro now we already compared
the performance between the a 12 X and
the new 812 Z chips and there honestly
isn't that big of a difference there's a
little bit of a bump in the graphics but
honestly the performance should stay
more or less the same the new iPad pro
does get 6 gigs of RAM compared to 4 on
most of the 2018 models but the big
difference that Apple mentioned was that
they improved the thermal performance on
the new 20/20 iPad pro now what we're
gonna do in this video is play 1 hour of
games on each of these iPads both set to
120 fps they're both at a hundred
percent battery life and we've set the
brightness to 80% on both of them as
well this way we can test the battery
drainage after an hour and see if
there's any overheating or screen
dimming or performance issues on either
of these iPads so here we are on the
2018 iPad pro as you can see I use Siri
to set the brightness to 80% we're also
at 100% battery life right there and I
am using the Xbox one controller right
here and right there you can see we're
at 120 FPS on the 2018 iPad pro so let's
get into a game we're gonna see if we
experience any screen glitching or
dimming or performance issues I've gotta
say using a controller is amazing so far
I haven't experienced any issues
whatsoever oh man didn't notice that guy
whoo aah
come on right behind me all right so far
so good no performance issues or nothing
like that
whoa that was close so I've got to say
I'm extremely impressed with the 2018
iPad pro no performance issues
whatsoever still playing incredibly
smooth come on oh that was so close man
are you kidding all right guys and here
we are on the 20/20 iPad pro as you can
see it's 312 right now we've just set
the brightness to 80% and we're at a
hundred percent battery life we are at
the same 120 fps just like on the 2018
model just like the 2018 model
everything feels incredibly smooth
somebody's over here
got him
whoa that was close man
oh come on bro
so far no screen dimming on this iPad
pro I'm not sure if it's slightly
brighter than the 2018 or if that one
did dim but this is working perfectly
everything feels super smooth on the
2020 model probably the biggest
difference we're gonna see is the
difference in battery drain so I'm
excited to see which one drains more oh
I was like blind fireman oh you how did
I even miss that alright guys I'm in cod
mobile now on the 2018 iPad pro as you
can see graphics and the frame rate are
on very high got him get out of here bro
man I love controller support Oh
whoo got one said it do that was easy so
far in this game no performance issues
either works perfectly fine I'm not
seeing any screen dimming either it's
great to see that we're not getting any
performance issues with an iPad pro
that's a year and a half old in these
new modern games especially with 120 FPS
support come on get out of here bro
gotcha
all right guys as you can see it's 221
it's been just about an hour of gameplay
playing for tonight and Cod mobile now
we're looking at 70% battery life at 80%
brightness
after an hour all right guys here we are
on the 20/20 iPad pro in Cod mobile so
let's get into it
all right on the 20/20 iPad pro I fully
expect this to perform just as well I'm
missing
come on Bros ah come on
what nice
come on I only got two guys there yes
got 1200 all right now this map I like
gotcha
[Music]
two more points guys one more
one more yes final kill all right guys
it's for 12 right now it's been exactly
an hour and on the twenty twenty iPad
pro eighty percent brightness we are at
77% yep that's right alright guys there
you have it that was our stress test
playing for night in cod Mobile for one
hour on both the 2018 iPad pro and the
20/20 iPad pro so for performance I did
not notice any issues with either of
them they both performed perfectly well
everything was perfectly smooth no
issues at all as far as the displayed
aiming I honestly did not notice that on
the 2018 model or the 20/20 now the
biggest difference I noticed between
these two iPad pros was the battery life
the 2018 model was left at 70% after an
hour compared to 77 percent on the 2020
model now it was expecting maybe 2 to 3
percent difference but 7 percent I was
not expecting that so I've got to say
that even though that performance was
about the same on both of them that's
because the 2018 model was already
extremely powerful I know a lot of
people are saying that the a12 Z chip in
the 2020 model is exactly the same
identical to the a12 X just with a GPU
core unlocked but seeing this battery
life difference during gameplay I've got
to say I'm really impressed so basically
the conclusion to this video is that
both ipad pro's are an excellent choice
for gaming but the 20/20 model is just a
little bit better and the really nice
thing about it is that now it has double
the storage it comes with 128 gigabytes
instead of 64 gigabytes on the 2018
model at the base $800 price so even
though you might find the 2018 model on
sale for 674 dollars I would honestly
recommend just buying the 2020 model
because you get double the storage and
you get the extra features like the
ultra wide camera that lidar scanner
better internet reception with Wi-Fi 6
compared to the old Wi-Fi on the 2018
model so between these two iPads I would
definitely recommend the 20/20 iPad pro
for those extra features hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video if you did tap
that like button and click the circle
above to subscribe and make sure to
check out one of those two videos right
over there including our full 2018 verse
2020 I pad Pro comparison thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]